[Music]
hi everybody and welcome to the data
science hangout
if you're joining for the first time
today i'm rachel it's great to meet you
if this is your first hangout this is an
open space for the whole data science
community to connect and chat about data
science leadership
questions you're facing and what's going
on in the world of data science
the sessions are recorded and shared to
the r studio youtube
as well as the data science hangout site
which tyler someone from the rstudio
team can share in the chat as well but
you can always go back and re-watch or
find helpful resources
and we do also have a linkedin group so
if you ever want to continue
a conversation and meet with people you
can connect there too
but together we're we're all dedicated
to making this a welcoming environment
for everyone
so we love when everybody can
participate and we can hear from
everyone
so with that said there's three ways
that you can ask questions today you can
jump in the conversation by raising your
hand on zoom and i can call you in
you can also put questions in the zoom
chat
and feel free to just put a little
star next to it if you want me to read
it out loud instead if maybe a dog's
barking or you're in a coffee shop or
something but we also have a slido link
where you can ask questions anonymously
too i think tyler's sharing that in the
chat right this second
just want to reiterate we love to hear
from everybody no matter your level of
experience
or the area or industry of your work as
well
but for today i'm so excited to be
joined by my co-host adam fly founder
and ceo at system
and adam i'd love to kick things off by
maybe having you introduce yourself and
sharing a little bit about your work
sure um thanks so much for having me
it's a pleasure to to be here and i look
forward to a great conversation
um yeah so um uh i found a system um a
few years ago
and we recently launched uh to the
public just a few months ago actually
after a few years of r d
um
i'm uh i'm a scientist by my background
um started life
doing genetics and biochemistry grew up
in montreal
and kind of quickly got excited about
not just the application of science
itself and the pursuit of science um all
things of that from sort of wet lab to
computational
um but also in sort of just the general
application of scientific thinking and
scientific methods to problems that on
their surface don't seem scientific um
and so it's it's clear that you know we
want to apply scientific methods and
scientific thinking to things biomedical
and things environmental but maybe not
to how we think about global development
or how we think about poverty or how we
think about
food security
and i think the more we can advance the
tools of scientific thinking and the
scientific method um to address those
kinds of problems
um the better the world would be and so
that's kind of the the central thesis
that motivates my my work and my career
um i um yeah so super briefly um
uh most recently after founding seed
scientific data science companies
several years ago where we worked with
organizations like the united nations
and governments around the world to
apply
data science and machine learning in the
very early days very very early phase of
the data revolution when our team was
made up of scientists and engineers who
today we would call data scientists and
data engineers machine learning
engineers
started working on a host of
applications of data science and machine
learning to optimizing polio vaccine
distribution around the world
advancing the sustainable development
agenda at the u.n all the way through to
building the recommender system uh for
beats music when they were the
headphones trying to go up against
spotify
um and that led to
uh then selling the company to the
company acquired by spotify and and i
had that sort of great
um
uh
pleasure privilege of joining an
incredible team at spotify an incredible
leadership team and um
figuring out how do we go from uh what
was at the time a pretty small
kind of analytics function maybe 20 30
people
um into
what it is today sort of several hundred
people around the world um distributed
into every part of spotify's business
um
using data to drive um spotify's mission
in the world
i left spotify a few years ago
to start system um
and yeah super briefly there happy to
jump into this further
our mission at system is to
relate everything
um to help the world see and solve
anything as a system
the motivation behind system is a
further extension of sort of this
lifelong belief that if we can advance
the tools of scientific thinking to
problems that aren't on their surface
scientific all things will be improved
in the world um to me when i think about
sort of the biggest issues in the world
today
um we're in the midst of a pandemic
we see emerging epidemics uh confronting
us today
we're facing the real implications of
climate change around the world
we're seeing the challenges of systemic
racism particularly in the united states
um we're seeing the impact of
geopolitics in uh in russia and ukraine
not only of course affecting populations
there but affecting food security and
geopolitics around the world all these
important issues are highly systemic
they're highly interconnected they're
highly interdependent
and so if you're a scientist they
exhibit properties of complex systems
and i'm i'm a student of complexity
science
and have long been fascinated by
the application of complexity science
and broadly speaking systems thinking to
understanding the nature of the problems
in the world
and
our mission is really to recognize that
the way we organize data and information
in the world today
i'm happy to jump into all these themes
which is largely based on language
so when you search for information today
you get back things that semantically
match what it is your query is all about
but language doesn't know systems
language doesn't know
the relationship between climate change
and migration
uh and food security
and we believe that by understanding how
things are related by elevating with the
relationships between things and those
being statistically based relationships
we can drive a more holistic
understanding
of problems in the world of problems we
face in business the problems we face
when we get a blood test result
really anywhere that we get data
we feel it's lacking context and the
system around it and so what we're
really trying to do is build a
technology that brings context that
brings that holistic view to any data
point that we're looking at at any given
moment supported
the final point is that we're a public
benefit corporation
and
our mission
to relay everything to help the world
see and solve anything as a system is
really what motivates us and our values
as a company
system is free and open uh it's
available under creative commons license
um
we recently were had the sort of honor
of uh introducing bringing uh the former
ceo of wikipedia kathryn maher onto our
board of directors
um and so that's the the john the
long-term direction of system as a
system.com as our core platform is
really something that will be free and
open and accessible to researchers
professionals in the general public
around the world
that's awesome thank you so much adam
and thanks for describing systems
thinking a little bit too so i think so
many of us here are probably systems
thinkers but maybe not necessarily
calling it that or having the name for
it
but i wanted to start while we're
waiting for questions to come in from
everyone i want to start asking this
people every time so we can get to know
you a little bit better too
i'm curious what's something that you
like to do in your free time or outside
of work as well
um i love to cook um that's sort of my
my other kind of passion in life um
uh so uh
spend a good amount of time over the
last couple of years um especially
during the pandemic uh outside of i live
in new york so outside of the city and
it's been great to
grow vegetables and be able to go out
and pick stuff and make dinner um so i'm
i'm
yeah enjoying learning to garden and
really love to cook
yeah that's great
so i get to ask the first questions
before people start typing them in here
so i'm curious
you came from
spotify and you mentioned growing a team
from 20 to hundreds and then moving
towards your own startup what has it
been like working with
such different sizes of teams
yeah um
my company
see scientific before spotify that we
sold to spotify we were um yeah about 50
people or so 40 50 people um
and um yeah my team in spotify when i
left was 300 or something like that um
and now we're at 20-person startup
something like that um
there's honestly there's so many upsides
to both
um it's it's incredible to be able to
um
really start from first principles when
you're building a team as we've done at
system and emphasize
values that are native to our
culture and our mission
and then build a team that
advances
those values and you know we can really
think about uh all of that stuff
foundationally in how we hire and how we
design our ways of working
um the same time you know our ambition
for system is quite large and you know
we'd love to have 2 000 people today to
be able to work on these problems um and
so sometimes i wish you know i could
take the same organization and spotify
and be able to use that full incredible
brain power and tech power to be able to
work on our mission
and hopefully we'll get there um
spotify was an incredible it was an
incredible challenge to go from you know
30 people to 300 people
um over two years um so just incredible
scale of of how do you hire that many
people how do you uh train that many
people um we reached a point because we
were hiring globally um that they're
simply you know there's just not enough
kind of people that we at the time this
was three four years ago or five years
ago we started that process uh could
hire and so we actually invested
quite considerably in our own internal
um
university uh to train um engineers and
marketers and product managers and
designers who might have had the
quantitative methodological kind of
instincts but um
hadn't been trained in data science and
so we we thought it was going to be
really important to build those kinds of
education programs that continues today
sort of incredible team working on
professional development and sort of
growing data scientists
at spotify
um
yeah uh
um
i i think at the same time like what
unites it is um i i really believe in
trying to identify what are the
um
kind of primitives uh that allow teams
spotify is a very strong agile
belief and that really means kind of
decentralization federation of as much
decision making as possible to increase
speed and autonomy and ownership and i
really believe in that regardless of
size of team and so that means i think
as a leader that you i learned from from
daniel actually the founder of spotify
observing him do that that it it really
puts a great deal of emphasis on what
are the what are the primitives that you
feel are important for every leader in
the company and then for their teams to
really embrace and understand and really
make sure people really get
so that then you can empower teams to be
agile to be squads to go off and do
their thing and so we we put a great
deal of emphasis and system on
a set of first principles that govern
how we think about the product and our
technology and the tensions that shape
any major decision
we put a great deal of emphasis on our
values and talk a lot about those and
use those as primitives when we're
making
product decisions or technology
decisions and we put a great deal of
emphasis on sort of the use of data um
broadly in the company to inform our
decision making and so by really
equipping everybody with those three
things and we talk about that truly from
day one
onward through professional development
and one-on-ones and everything that
system
it allows for
i think a high degree of of ownership
and autonomy and sort of distributed
decision making around the company and
that's something i learned applying now
again at another startup but from
seeing that manifest at a several
thousand person technology company that
really valued that kind of thing
absolutely that's great i see there's
quite a few questions starting to come
in now and mike i see you put one in the
chat do you want to jump in and ask that
sure so i was just interested to know
what kinds of tools are you using to
you know build these systems models or
you know estimate parameters and how do
you evaluate the the kind of combined
models of all these different parts
against
the outcomes that you're interested in
yeah
um uh i'll give you the you know couple
minute answer and then um all of our
documentation all of our technical
documentation is is up on on our website
and would encourage if you have interest
to
get more um insight into the science and
technology behind it um please read that
and our data science team has done a
great job to to communicate that i think
um
so system um
is a platform that starts from
um
identifying sources of raw statistical
evidence in the world
and that evidence today exists in a
number of different places for us we've
identified three in particular
those are
the corpus of scientific literature in
the world so papers that get published
every day
in every part of science through the
great work of the research community and
funding agencies to advance scholarship
the second is the advancement of open
data and real world evidence that sits
in
data warehouses and portals and so forth
um measuring things like
covet vaccination rates and vaccine
hesitancy rates and so on and so forth
and world bank figures and omf figure
and so on uh imf figures um and then um
the third is uh a growing volume of
machine learning models
um out in the world predicting a whole
host of
outcomes from housing prices to food
security and so forth and so we've built
software to
identify
evidence of a statistical association
in any of those raw materials
or the potential to compute one
so from a scientific paper it's a
retrieval project from a data set it's a
computation project it's time series
analysis it's actually running
correlation analyses on data
from machine learning models we've built
r and python packages that allow our
teams today and we'll eventually open
this up
to
compute um
the importance of features in uh
in in predicting an outcome
uh in a test set and then we'll look at
that as well that future importance is
yet another input into the full set of
inflows coming into system so we've got
all these inflows coming in
then we have a huge job of normalization
and entity resolution um so yes like we
recognize you know
dozens and dozens and dozens and dozens
of types of statistical association from
odds ratios to rct experiments to
shop values to so on and so forth to
correlation coefficients and all these
things and the metadata around them so
the strength of that relationship the
controls that were put on that
experiment um the sign the direction all
sorts of attributes of that relationship
we retrieve
and we have to make sense of uh you know
being able to relate one data point one
piece of evidence to another so we do
all that work and then we have to
resolve on the name level
that you know obesity is an important
topic that our users want to be able to
search for and understand what's the
relationship
between obesity and diabetes
but because there's lots of different
ways
metrics variables of measuring obesity
body mass index body mass index over 30
patient has declared themselves
self-identified as obese so on and so
forth all of those then need to be
grounded within the what we call the
topic of obesity so then that's the next
part of our platform
then all of this gets organized in a
large scale graph database um
and then the way we traverse that graph
database when a user searches system
is not based on language so as i was
saying so it's the core architecture of
the core information architecture of
search and discovery today is based on
language right so you search google for
housing prices
google's knowledge graph will relate
housing prices semantically to home
prices and real estate prices and then
rank that and give you the new york
times article at the top
um
system is saying cool we need to get to
housing prices but then what we're
really interested in is in all of the
factors that system knows one degree two
degrees and so forth away
are being
impacting housing prices or being
affected by it um and then we assemble
all of that visualize that in a graph
and present all of the evidence
alongside that for the user so that's
the core proposition
and then we're building applications on
top of that but that's what you can find
today and at a very high level kind of
how things work
thanks adam
i see there was an anonymous question
that came in first which was what do you
think about as a ceo that you never
thought of as a functional specific lead
i think a lot about um
the values and culture of the company um
right so at spotify i
you know was an active participant in
helping advance our values
and advance our culture and and
hopefully you know positively contribute
to it but
i inherited those values from
a founder and a founding team
and those are his and their you know
decisions about what's what is important
here um and what what really unifies us
and what will be the lens through which
we will
make the hardest decisions hopefully um
at system i spend an incredible amount
of my time
um
thinking about those values initially
and now
really making sure that i'm equipping
our our team and our leadership team
with the
tools and the case studies from around
the company for how to apply those
things
very practically so i'll give you an
example
um openness is a core value of ours and
we believe as is as is
so positive impact in the world and we
believe that a big problem with the way
technology companies especially those of
us who traffic in data and ai and
historically haven't been scrutinized
the same way that defense companies or
you know energy companies might have
been scrutinized by the public
i'm really encouraged by you know the
general direction of our field towards
greater
um
sense of accountability for the bias in
our work for the impact of our work for
the unintended consequences of our work
but i think this you know it starts with
establishing that as a culture it
continues in actually making sure it's
practiced but then one of the things
we're trying to do and we were very open
we sort of published a blog post about
this a couple months ago is our
um uh
vp of product and engineering and our vp
of a team we call global issues kind of
working on systems application to
world problems like global health where
we're doing work with the gates
foundation
published a blog post on something we're
calling release risks um so tech
companies are used to publishing release
notes um alongside all their major
releases and you know so here's great
features we've just released and our
idea was we wanted to publish alongside
our first major release which was a
couple months ago
um all the things we see that could be
unintended consequences of putting this
out in the world as a release
um and so we laid those out after a
process we ran internally and then um
went through point by point how we have
set out to mitigate those potential
consequences where we still see risk how
we plan to improve on that and then you
know hold us to account on what we plan
to show you by the next major release
that's the kind of thing that really
stemmed directly from our values into an
action that then our leadership team you
know took forward um as a practice of
our value so that's the kind of thing i
spent a lot of my time thinking about
especially given the mission and the
nature of our company as a pbc
um that i just wasn't able to given
not being a founder um at spotify
thanks adam i see travis you asked a
great question that i see libby just
upvoted as well travis do you want to
jump in and ask that
yeah sure um there's been a lot of
chatter i've seen on
twitter linkedin among our data science
peers about
you know
when is the right time to kind of
start a business make a startup how does
one like what are the first steps one
would take get seed funding those sorts
of things and intriguing that you came
from large successful org like spotify
and were able to spin off something
successful now with system um there's
really good talk at our studio comp from
um david kais about what they forgot to
teach you about starting a business um
so i mean yeah there's a lot of interest
in this and i'm curious myself like you
know when you know the time is right
what do you do what's the next steps do
you know like angel investors is it like
a network thing is it something else um
what does that look like
yeah um
yeah i think it's a great question and i
i think it's awesome that um
uh so many
especially over the last like couple of
years um
have been feeling
the
motivation to
um to sort of break out um to
start new things and see a problem and
just go off and and pursue it and i
think that's that's awesome i mean i'm
um i i believe in that i sort of try to
help as many founders as i can i have a
general rule i actually think like all
founders kind of believe this is you
know if another founder reaches out to
you for help you just you help like you
you take the call so i do this a lot
like i'll just like go have coffee with
the founder who's you know thinking
about something struggling with
something trying to raise their seed
round dealing with their first crisis
whatever um so you know
it's it's it's a it's a hard it's a hard
thing to do um to start something
to lead something to grow something to
deal with
a recession to you know all the things
that you start to confront um when
you're in charge
um and so
you know support networks are so
important i think
a couple things i would say is is um
a lot of those support networks
historically have not been accessible to
a great proportion of founders who
aren't part of
you know
white males who are like predominated in
tech um and so like these networks have
been seemingly quite close my my my wife
is a female uh
uh
arab entrepreneur founder and she also
puts a huge amount of emphasis on
kind of supporting
um
women who are starting companies and
access to vcs uh it's so we we both just
like believe deeply and and how do we
broaden the
access for founders or new founders to
to resources to introductions to things
like that so
it's kind of like acknowledge that
that's a problem as well it's a lot you
don't have if you don't have the network
kind of a priority like where do you
start getting that network so hopefully
one thing is just like reaching out to
other founders i really i really believe
that like most founders
i want to hope
will will take your call just because
they
i remember what it was like and the very
first time just kind of reaching out to
other founders and
cold and just like seeking guidance and
like validation and you know anything
and so
that i would encourage that seems very
simple but do that and hopefully more of
us will take the call
um
to the point of like when you know um
so i i've always seen entrepreneurship
for me personally and others view this
very differently so i you know i can
only speak to my experience
my motivation for starting things is
really because
um
i feel that
we need to build something in response
to some societal challenge
and
um
i will have the best impact over the
next several years of my life waking up
and living and breathing this
through
this venue
as opposed to working on this problem
another way
so system is a very big problem it's not
hours to have i i didn't wake up one
morning and say you know what the world
is highly complex and interconnected and
if only we could understand how
everything was related that would change
everything i mean ada lovelace wrote
about this and bucky fuller and
you know
any number of great scholars and stephen
hawking and and on and on and on um
um
michelle alexander in in writing the new
jim crow so it's like across the
spectrum people have recognized the need
for taking a systems-based approach and
so when i was at spotify and i sort of
knew that this was the next major
problem i wanted to work on in my life i
gave my first talk about this at arse
electronica
12 13 14 15 years ago and i basically
laid out system without knowing that it
was system
it took me a long time to figure out how
to do this and like is this even
tractable um
and then it was at spotify that like the
tech part started to resonate with me i
i sort of
felt i could do this like this was this
would be technically tractable and that
a technological solution to this big
problem
would be high leverage towards advancing
systems thinking and systems based
approaches in the world
i also at that time i had spent time at
at
kennedy school of government um uh as a
fellow working on broadly
um the place of data and science and
society um i've spent time advising the
un
um i've worked at a big company and so i
did kind of reflect on should i just
like go do this from a university
platform from a research platform from a
social sector platform from big tech
and then ultimately
recognize that really the nature of the
problem the nature of what gets built
here
would be ill-served if i could it needs
to be built and it would be bad if i
built this
you know at another technology company
um
it would compromise the sort of
integrity of what it is we're trying to
do so that that was it was really that
thing and then like the next week i was
on a flight to stockholm and talked to
daniel and that was it that was the
beginning of sort of building system
thanks
and if anybody is starting let me like
please reach out i'm happy to chat more
about
the more particularities of you know
where do you access capital blah blah
blah
that's great thank you adam and maybe if
there are people interested in that i
can we could help connect through the
linkedin group as well or
awesome
um i see there's a few questions in the
chat that came in recently too and sally
i see you asked the great one do you
want to jump in and ask that
hey yeah thanks rachel hey adam so
as an entrepreneur or
well i was an entrepreneur but the thing
is i really appreciate that hustle that
you have and one of the questions i had
is you know starting a company and
having one two three employees it's easy
to
it's easier to
keep that vision that you have for the
company and the values of the company
but when you start adding in say
200 200 300 people in your company and
as it grows bigger and bigger how do you
what do you look for when you hire to
where you
can
keep your company's values and missions
and visions um but also you know with
different talent they have their own
set of
creativity and beliefs and all that
stuff so yeah turn it floor to you
yeah um a great question and and that
that is really something that i spend a
lot of my time thinking about um our our
director of operations i see is also on
this call and uh so i spent a lot of
time talking with with esther about this
as well um
uh
so
it starts with it starts with how we
hire um
there
uh are
you know any number of philosophies of
kind of what to prioritize and how much
time to take and especially in
competitive job markets and so on and so
forth
we've
held um
and and i've uh
been
i've used my founder political capital
let's say right to sort of like advocate
for this very strongly and and
ensure this was part of our culture from
the beginning
that we um do a couple of things that
just like extend the amount of time
sometimes it takes to really like get to
know somebody beyond like the technical
screens and stuff like that
um but we we put a great deal of
emphasis on how we discuss our values
with a candidate um
and
once somebody starts a system uh they'll
get
shad they'll shadow somebody else on the
team to go do one of those values
interviews and then
they're off to the races leading those
values interviews so it's really
something that we believe
it must be something that everybody in
the company especially from different
teams right like who've never met a
candidate are just meeting this person
and we've just put a lot of time into
refining the questions and cases and
things that we use to
just try to like have a conversation
with somebody and get to the heart of
you know will they be
ambassadors for values that we all um
never only just me we all just believe
our poor to the culture we feel very
proud of
um we also
[Music]
have you know introduced kind of a
a project with our candidates
that
can be
taken any form but it's a way of us kind
of
uh getting to discuss something as a
system with a candidate and those two
things sort of our values discussion and
this project around systems
for us
um
and we've talked about so many times
right like so many times we'll have a
conversation with our leadership team
about
like this takes time and
you know this candidate is gonna has
like two job offers from
two great companies and
and i just like really believe that this
stuff matters um and like we just have
an incredible incredible incredible team
um
and you know incredibly low attrition
and like all those things just like
great productivity great collaboration
and great spirit around the company um
so i i think it's just like you know
what are the things that are really
important that you just believe are
really important and to make time for
those things and you know at the end of
the day competitive markets all that
kind of stuff you have to be respectful
of the candidates time
most importantly but you know
you're trying to
build a value-centered company that's
going to scale the only way it scales
the only way i know how i should say
that it scales is by putting an
over emphasis on this stuff for the
first 10 20 30 40 because then
like the most exciting some of the most
exciting moments for me over the last
like year
is when i'll meet a candidate during
onboarding who i had nothing to do with
hiring
and i'm just like i emailed the hiring
manager i'm just like that was incred
like the questions they asked me that
she asked me during onboarding
were just like mind-blowingly awesome um
and like i you know and like i see two
months later like she's thriving or
something and
yeah that just feels great um that just
means like the primitives are there
and
yeah you just have to like hold on to
that stuff
if you if what you're trying to do is
build a company that is going to scale
and
um is values driven and that's not the
only way right like some founders start
things because they see a
clear opportunity and they just want to
seize it and like go super fast and sell
it as quickly as possible and
capitalism allows that too so
that's just not what motivates me it's
not how i think about it so that's what
i do
that's great thank you so much adam
thank you and and adam diving into that
a little bit deeper too
i'm curious what are some of the
questions or
or how do you actually get at like if
someone's values are aligned
um
it's hard for me to i guess it's hard
for me to to like just share those
questions as you know because they're
not i mean there's a long list of things
that teams will pick from based on the
nature
but i think we we generally find
um
that the best way is to try to like get
to cases um is to get to real world
examples where somebody is
struggling with some tension or having
to you know make a decision about
something and we're trying to see how
they've considered that value
um in in some personal decision or some
life decision or some business decision
or some managerial decision we're just
trying to get a feel for it and
everybody is coming in with their own
like very diverse backgrounds and we
have tried to build like a very very um
diverse uh and inclusive culture um
especially
at like ever i mean at every level of
our company um
but across the board it's been it's been
uh critical to
uh to me from day one
and so we also acknowledge that people
are coming in with very different ways
of and very different having had
different opportunities to
manifest values differently
um
and so we try to just like educate our
team and make sure that our team is
empathetic to the specific context of a
candidate um but also you know these are
the five things that we really look for
and it's okay if you know that's not you
and you'll thrive somewhere else those
are the five that matter to us so
yeah i'd be hard-pressed to like give
you one and make it seem representative
right yeah but that's sort of the
philosophy definitely thank you and i
see there's
a lot of conversation going on in the
chat and tanya
if you want to jump in but uh
tanya said giving kudos she was stalking
your team page and said
when i give major kudos for building a
talented and diverse team nice to see
that especially in tech
thank you
let me go back over to slido and see
some of the anonymous questions there
too
um
one um that was asked earlier was going
back to your work at spotify and ask was
your work more related to
delivering a better listening experience
so songs and playlists or other things
like ui ux
um all of it so we we
we developed uh
um
an organizational design and kind of
structure at spotify
for that phase um and spotify as a
culture as a company
um really subscribes to even being agile
and kind of responsive in how it
organizes itself um so we you know would
spin up new squads and
deprecate squads and merge squads and
change things based on
where things were growing and where
things were changing and what we were
learning from users and market and that
same philosophy
kind of even manifested in in how the
organization um itself like bigger
picture um
changes over time and evolves over time
so then the challenge was
we were both not
this is the challenge of many
organizations as they kind of go through
growth
we were both not
able to invest
in our
kind of core
data
analytics machine learning
platform culture and products
while also not able to
scale to meet the very nuanced
applications of all of that to
product and content and markets and
sales and marketing and strategy and you
know all of the very many functions of
spotify around the world
and so we built both a
large
um
central organization uh that was working
on core platform core culture core data
tooling
core data sets core analytics core
machine learning models all this kind of
stuff
um
and with a very strong emphasis on
education again so how do we
um help as many people as spotify as
possible
um get trained in the tools needed to be
data literate so that
our work would have the greatest
absorptive capacity ultimately impact
you know in people's lives and work
and then a whole distributed
organization that was embedded in all of
those functions so from you know product
analytics like you're saying and making
those a b test
considerations and helping to design
those experiments in a product squad
way through to
you know what's the best marketing
campaign to grow subscribers in japan
all the way through to which new artist
is gonna break
all the way through to
um how do we better understand a
person's taste
in order to create new features that can
be the basis for new recommendation
products
like time capsule that is
was an effort to
predict music
that would evoke feelings of nostalgia
for you individually based on an
incredible amount of research an
incredible team working on sort of the
behavioral sciences
of
these psychological um
experiences uh and then building
algorithms building models to to predict
that and help to evoke that for for
listeners at their choice so really
across the spectrum um
yeah all really um and with a goal of
how do we be as
um
thoughtful as possible in how to do this
in a manner that was consistent with
spotify's values um
but also
at the time i mean we were sitting and
looking at
the three biggest technology companies
in the world as our competitors
and it was part of the strategy of the
company that
data would be and continues to be
one of the ways
to
materially differentiate and compete um
so also with the very real world
business challenge of you know we need
this to go up against google apple and
amazon
that's so cool to hear about it
i always think about that listening to
spotify i'm like wow they really got me
there they knew just what song to put on
there
um i see jeremy you asked a question in
the chat do you want to jump in
sure
thanks adam uh really interesting
product
i have a question about the occasional
revelation of bad science i think
something around alzheimer's was
recently uncovered maybe a decade or
generation of
research was based on bad data
as a consumer
of science i'm wondering if there's a
way or how you would unroll that in your
graph and then how you would surface
that to me as the user is there a way i
can sort of
i don't know go back in time on certain
relationships and see where they
diverged or where they were rolled back
or where you might notify me in the tool
that something really big has happened
yeah uh incredibly important question
one of the things we're most focused on
actually um
uh
like active kind of product discussions
just in even the last couple weeks for
some things we're working on right now
so
um
a few different ways that we're thinking
about that um the first is that we
um believe in presenting all evidence on
system as
transparently as we possibly can so we
we are showing
showing the work right we're showing the
source um of of all relationships that
are being constructed on system we're
showing the statistical information that
system is retrieving we're showing any
controls that were
placed on that experiment we're showing
um the
strength of that relationship we're
showing all of that so it starts with
just right it's not sort of this opaque
um like there is a relationship here
trust us so the first thing is just like
we believe fundamentally in
making sure that all evidence on system
is there and available
and we our design team spends a lot of
time thinking about how to make that as
clear and compelling as possible if you
choose to go dig into the underlying
evidence so number one is just
firm belief we have first principle we
have a value
it's codified in like the architecture
of the platform that we store all of
that metadata we expose as much of it as
possible and we use design to try to
make it as clear and compelling for the
user as possible
then as we aggregate more and more
information about a given relationship
so an alzheimer's relationship for
example um
where we are going now and you can see
this on a relationship page today so if
you um click on any edge in the graph or
if you search for any topic
and click on a relationship
you'll see that as there are multiple
sources of evidence and so we're going
to go from tens to hundreds and
thousands very very very shortly some
exciting things on our end
you will see
synthesis coming from system
around the extent to which
there is consensus or not
um in the evidence that system has
gathered about this particular
relationship and so when there is
actually evidence of disagreement
um that will be there and you'll be able
to really see what was the context for
that disagreement
in the particular
paper or data source or particular
facet of that relationship
then um the sort of final piece is that
we are um
uh
yeah very interested in the evolution of
these relationships over time so every
piece of evidence on system
has its timestamp of when um it was
gathered in the world as well as when it
was added to system of course and so
in the future you will be able to see
the evolution of information on the
platform the evolution of consensus the
evolution of value
in a given relationship
so we're working on some some
interesting things there that i'm quite
excited about
um the the final piece is that we've
built a community around the platform um
of system thinkers who come from all
walks of life from health care to
education to
um to climate change to technology and
um we
and they we have our slack community and
you're all very much welcome to um
please join us and if you feel
passionate about sort of the
applications of systems thinking in the
world
please join the conversation
so we will be introducing tools to then
bring the power of community
into these areas like biomedical
research or climate change or elsewhere
and apply that extra level of kind of
human filter um
on top of the technology that we've
built um so we're learning a lot from
you know platforms like wikipedia
um on how they deal with these kinds of
things and these are not error-proof
platforms by any means um great
scientific journals have been duped in
these kinds of things
so um the best thing we could be doing
is um these are the steps we're taking
um i think this is an improvement from
just
driving towards kind of a consensus view
on something and then we never see
disagreement
um
and we don't see change over time we
think those are some of the things we
can be doing to
you know not stop um what is ultimately
just
bad behavior from people um and then a
system that doesn't catch it
but
at least use technology to the extent
possible to detect those kinds of things
to create transparency around this sort
of evidentiary basis for a relationship
awesome thanks yeah and this too by the
way
incredibly important topic to us to our
product teams our data science team so
if you have thoughts um
we're all ears uh on on our community on
these kinds of topics so do feel free to
share any thoughts papers things you
think we should be reading as we think
about this um
yeah please do
great thank you
um i see ali you had asked a question
earlier do you want to ask that live
and i can i can read it too but the
question was
hi newbie here what advice do you have
for someone trying to transition into
data science
um yeah great question um
yeah i mean my my uh
my general belief is that um it's it's
very helpful to start
um especially given kind of my my own
interest in data science and what it can
be used for most
meaningfully in a company in society and
government in a hospital is to is to
really start with statistics and and
make sure that
you invest the time
before you're kind of working with data
before you're building things um to
really just uh yeah
get indoctrinated with sort of core
principles and statistics
it will serve you
beyond anything that that you know any
new tool or technology that you will
adopt in my view
um because it will give you the the
shared critical lens on information
um that will carry you throughout your
career
whether you stay in you know practical
applied data science
shift into
machine learning go into you know
product management or marketing you will
have like taken the foundational like
data science as a science at the end of
the day and we have spent a huge amount
of time for very good reason over the
last few years as a field focusing on
the engineering side of data science and
like all this great tooling
because we needed to like just deal with
all this data and figure out how to
build models and deploy them into
production and then deal with you know
whatever all all the stuff and now we've
got a plethora of things i think to go
use but
like the science is the thing like
what's the real value add if you think
about it in three years from now and
you're sort of about your ceo and you're
evaluating like what's the level of
investment we should be making in data
science versus
whatever
it's going to be based on the quality of
those insights and the actionability of
those insights and the value that comes
from the products and models that are
being built but for those first couple
i mean that like at the end of the day
just making sure that there are core
scientific practices and good scientific
rigor you are thinking rigorously about
what you're controlling for you're
thinking
rigorously about bias in the sample and
through that ensuring that you don't
introduce further bias into the decision
making in the company
you're thinking hopefully
as we are advocating for taking a more
systemic approach to looking at a
problem and thinking about it more
holistically what is impacting it what
is
the path to causal inference in this
particular problem area
so
that's where i would start and really
like hold on to those things and of
course then the rest of it is is a
little bit more
you know there's great resources and
great things to then educate yourself on
but yeah
stats i would just like really emphasize
that
okay i see some love from santiago in
the chat about uh statistics
and a lot of other a lot of other
thoughts too if if anybody wants to jump
in this question and on this question
and provide feedback too feel free to
raise your hand i see luke you have some
thoughts here too and libby
yeah i'm just reading that too i really
love that um libya your comment on that
too i think that's that's right because
i think um there's different ways of
coming at data science and so
um yeah i
would subscribe to that
yeah i don't feel like i have much
to add to that besides like
that's the first stop right like before
you jump into how do i do this or how do
i learn to code or how do i learn
statistics or machine learning
like ask yourself why you're doing it
and how you learn best because everybody
is completely different and you're going
to get 5 000 different pieces of advice
on how you should do it based on how
someone else did it and they're not you
right so
do you learn best in a classroom with
classmates and a teacher and somebody
that you have access to to ask a lot of
questions
that's me maybe you need to take a class
maybe an in-person class maybe that's
not you at all you're completely
auto-didactic then read a book you're
gonna be happier that way just stay true
to what works for you and don't get
sidetracked by what everybody else tells
you you should do
i love that thank you libby
i see caitlin you recommended a podcast
as well
in the chat that you were on on breaking
into data science
i can make sure to share that with our
like summary of the session on the
linkedin group too
yeah sure thanks yeah so basically on
the podcast i just talk about my kind of
journey into data science and i actually
come from a psychology background so
anyone who maybe comes from more of a
qualitative
background trying to get into data
science maybe that podcast would be
helpful
absolutely thank you i would also just
add that
especially for those who come from
either qualitative backgrounds or from
sort of natural sciences
um
it's incredibly valuable in my
experience to
[Music]
hold on um to those skills that you
nurtured in those areas because data
science is a fundamentally
interdisciplinary field in its best form
and so
if you orient visually
then you will be a great you know
advocate for
the merging of data science and data
visualization if you orient
qualitatively you'll be a great advocate
on your team for the synthesis of user
research and product analytics if you
orient towards natural sciences you'll
be a great advocate for thinking about
causal inference and is this a real
systems view of the problem and is the
experimental design
appropriate for what we're trying to do
with it
so
know that really you can come at it from
really any angle
and what you come with it what you come
to it with will be very valuable um
because it's a big tent and
will that will will benefit from all of
those prior experiences
i love
that
i see libby you had asked a question a
little bit earlier too i think about
books um
for systems thinking
yeah i was looking for recommendations
on books um i've heard a lot about
systems thinking before i haven't like
you know dove in and
and learned a ton so if anybody has any
recommendations janelle did say that she
joined the slack channel and that there
were book recommendations there so i'm
kind of traveling over to the slack
channel
awesome i see somebody had just asked on
slido adam where do you see system in
the next five years and
what help resources do you need the most
to achieve that
oh i think you're muted
i'm sorry um i hope in i hope in five
years from now um
system is is a resource for
decision making um in every field and
around the world where you come to
system either through
our platform itself or through apis that
we will expose two points of decision
making as we grow
so wherever it is you're trying to make
a decision about your health in the
context of meeting with a doctor or
doctors interacting with each other in
the context of a business where you're
trying to figure out what's changing and
moving a metric in the context of the
economy and we're trying to figure out
what policy decisions will
move
a particular
social
factor in the context of global health
where we're trying to understand and
anticipate what could be giving rise to
what changes in a particular metric
might impact an emerging epidemic
in a country
the thing that unifies all of these
things right now is that we are so
siloed
in the way we see these problems and we
simply don't have the tool
we don't have the ability to go access
the context for the decision we're
trying to make we're not able to go
query for what are all of the things we
already know
are related to our driving or being
driven by that thing that is so
important to you
to the city to the country to
your team
to the world at that moment and so
our vision is really to empower
everyone to be able to
access that system's view just as easily
as you can go on wikipedia or go on
google today
and get information about it
we want to make it even more accessible
for you to go understand the system
around it the context for it
awesome it's really exciting
i know i always say this but an hour
goes by so quickly
and i know there are a lot of questions
that i didn't yet get to so i just want
to give people the opportunity to just
raise your hand on zoom too if there's a
question that you asked and want to make
sure
we get to
this is a quick question that's okay
yeah sure
um adam do you use our r studio in your
company
we do
cool i didn't even know that
our you know our data science team is um
yep um
fans and and you've got some fans and uh
you've got some fans here for sure
that's great
um i see somebody else had asked earlier
to um what languages do you use
on your data science team
there's a lot of python as well
[Music]
and i mean generally we're
working across a very large stack and so
certainly in the data science realm
we're working in r and python um
but we're you know doing natural
language processing we're doing
information retrieval we're building
entity resolution systems we're doing
data visualization on the front end and
doing a lot of work there obviously
um
we're
you know building search uh so there's a
lot of parts of the stack and obviously
lots of languages across the board and
yeah we try to be promoters of um
as much openness as possible and and
open source as possible um
we ourselves will be making much of
systems
for our charter all of the data on
system all the metadata will be fully
open and accessible
um so we also you know want to embrace
and support um
advocates for for openness and tech
thank you so much adam for joining us
today and sharing your experience and a
great discussion
um i do just want to ask if people want
to connect with you is linkedin the best
way or what's best for you yeah
lincoln's linkedin's
linkedin is great that would be the
easiest thing
okay awesome
well thank you so much thank you
everybody for joining today too great to
see you and we'll be back same time same
place next week
you